Sam: Sometimes you just have to make videos that are super weird and don't have a concrete plan in an effort to kind of mix things
Up a little bit and kind of make video. That's a little more abstract [doesn't] really follow any particular
Rules or structure just enjoy the process of making it rather than analyzing the piece
We're on to vapes this one right here is just going to be this and these [two] straps right here
And they're going to kind of wrap around a typical vape. God vape pen then for this next one
It's actually a little bit more complicated when it's all put together
There's gonna be a tube coming out right here and then going into the battery part of it
And it's going to have the juice in there, so it's gonna look really kind of weird Gonna hit hard
[it's] kind of chuck the vapor. Hopefully jake doesn't yell at me don't yell at me
It's been three days since I've started working on this. We are very very very very very very very close to being [done]
This is kind of where we're at right now with the big vape
It's a bit jank here and there, but I think it looks pretty funny Sam was like hey while you're at
The hardware store, can you find anything to make like a second [fate]?
Just a little bit smaller, so I came up with this thing
It's just so out there like there's just the two with the baked juice in it like combining that one on top makes you stack
Up here oh my God
babe complete
I'm rolling whenever you're ready
I think we got a video right there another listing the bet thing it looks hilarious
That's how everyone's gonna vape in the video is just wheeling we're gonna start with the moment where everyone just like [ghost]
Nicotine free they do so yeah, I'm not trying to make a pro smoking [ad]
the goal of the days to come out of it with an up footage to edit a video and
Ideally the footage will be good or funny one of the two that doesn't need to be good as long as it's funny
And it doesn't need to be funny as long as this weird hopefully it's enough footage to make a video whether it's good bad weird
Or whatever be very sure what you put in this soy sauce sense of syrup maple syrup
Almost made me spill my date
[Rollin] and three two one action
ah
You were so red. I was like is this the cameras
Saturation it's actually pretty hard to vape it in [NL] while doing a [oh]
So bad, not a master vapor
This is my [Sansa] a team member at Corridor digital. Why the crazy ideas like this one?
I've never actually baked it before I've never taken a [pole] on [a] baby really yeah
Yeah, hold on. I got me
You know it's pretty good. It tastes like strawberry air
There's no nicotine in this I'm thankfully not gonna get hooked on one of the most addictive drugs none mankind those oh
So you're walking in like you know I'm here to save the [world]. What's up? I'm bringing my powers to the table
How about you? What do you bring in to [the] table? Take your fake, babe? You're like
boom do you exhale it out from the vape thing is the vaporizing [you] have to put like maximum energy levels into
Into inhaling and exhaling right now
Let's get so wide when we do it
[hahaha] you you turn into a different person
Why whoa?
Honestly, you're moving at such a consistent speed that you almost wouldn't attract that I'm gonna do it [again]
I'm going to shoot wider so we have more to track because I'm shooting at [6k]
We can crop in afterwards do big sweeping with motion with your arms
Pretty nice. That was great
So we're gonna get a wide shot [of] everyone. Good work [alright]
I'm going to come down there and get another one last shot and we're good good job
Super weird [right] [now]. It's feeling a little slow because [everything] slow-motion
You say then you can either decide to worry about it or not or [hey] about it
And it's life is a lot easier when you're not wearing here's the thing. I'm not gonna. Worry about it
I'm gonna work on it, and then we'll come to the end and I'll be halfway done like we got uploaded tomorrow
You know what? I'll just I'll let it be your problem [though]. I'll work as hard as I can
And call good. We're all this together so first
It's important to notice that there were a couple big breakthroughs for us as a company on this video one is that we got fumefx
4 which is an updated version of fume effects that we've used in the past
The other thing is that we got octane version 3 on top of a whole list of upgrades it is now able to do volumetric
Rendering and by that it's able to do smoke rendering fume effects is a smoke simulator octane is a light
simulator using the old rendering system
You would have to like turn off features because otherwise you would take far too long to render now octane on the other hand renders
Maximum full realistic unbiased quality all at once
Immediately, but it starts as a very like fuzzy noisy image
And that's because each pixel although correct is off by a little bit and so over time all the pixels are adjusting until they're perfectly
Right and that just takes a lot of time that's another cool thing about Octane
Is that you can take whatever time you [have] and render your entire sequence within that time you can take a shot and make it?
So that it only takes 10 seconds to render or 10 minutes the 10 minute one wall [waste] little better
But the light interaction itself will still be they're in the [low-quality] version [ok] so super quick rundown of the actual fema fex
Simulation Pipeline here [you] start with [your] volume you add some emitters and emitter is something that just emits
Smoke so for the purpose of this I've got four different emitters each coming from our heads
And they're shooting smoke down into the center between us. We've got to find the right settings to kind of Mimic your scenes outside
It's a little bit windier
So I added some
Turbulence so that you get a little bit more wisp enos to the smoke you can change the buoyancy of the smoke the temperature going
In how fast stuff rises how fast stuff dissipates eventually you get to a point where [like] [alright]?
I'm kind of happy with the way. This is looking. I'm going to try a high quality
Simulation you crank up the resolution [you] guys want a special [ren] pro tip for fume effects
Here's what I do simulate at a reasonably high res, but not mega high res then you take that and you apply
What's called wavelet turbulence you end up with high resolution looking smoke?
But you have low
resolution motion and
here's the thing about the internet [no] one's gonna notice that your motion is not high quality now after doing wavelet turbulence you have a
very very high resolution file
And it's also extremely big and from there you do what's called post-processing shrimps all of the fat out of it
It's like oh this [voxel] doesn't have any good information in it delete
oh
There's not really anything here except for a bunch of these channels
Delete you rake all the excess fat off of your simulation you end up with a much smaller file size
And that is what I bring into octane and render in summary do your simulation subdivided to make it really high resolution
Post process which takes away all the fat and now you're left with a really
streamlined high quality simulation that you throw into octane and it renders it really well the shots we have left are not easy shots that's
our issue
Which we can we can probably get all those shots simulated in the next day and a half but rendering will be an issue
We do have [two] octane licenses so I can get two renders going all night tonight
And another two renders all night tomorrow night, and maybe a render during the day as soon as I get this done
I'm gonna get it started rendering over on that so I can move on yeah at this point
It's just [a] race to the finish trying to get the rest of the shots done
I
Just finished the second last shot. It's Friday 1:30 p.m.
Bren is finishing the last shot that means we're gonna be done with the video once these are done rendering
[nine] hours 12 hours eight hours is
average just like what render
Depending on - I have at this one. Can you make my skimmer guy maybe a [three-and-A-half-hour] [marker] specifically three and half hours?
Yeah, cool. We're not going to do sound design for this video because
Right now the song we're using is very dense very
Intense [I] did edit the piece to kind of just fit with the track a little more like a music video than a narrative piece
Basically like stranger things, but with vaping yeah
Let's do I'm a little upset about how good
Team Man Sodo great work dude, and so good if you guys been following us on Instagram or Facebook heck
Have you been watching these videos all year you're probably familiar with a very big secret
Project that we've [been] [working] on good news and the very next video on this channel
[we're] going [to] be releasing a teaser for that project [make] sure you have all your notifications
Turned on so that when we release it you are immediately notified you do not want to miss it
This is the largest project. We've ever worked on and we're incredibly excited to share it with you guys